[Music]
that's
nature celebrating their new documentary
reveals the astonishing ways that nature
flourished as humans went into lockdown
during the pandemic
the year earth changed on apple tv plus
is narrated by the legendary natural
historian
sir david attenborough overnight
our lives are put on pause
[Music]
but as we stop remarkable things
start to change in the natural world
clearer air cleaner waters
and animals starting to flourish
in ways we haven't seen for decades
i have two more examples in a non-david
attenborough voice from the film
with no humans on the beach the nesting
success rate for loggerhead sea turtles
in florida jumped
to 61 percent that is the highest
scientists have ever seen
and in san francisco with car traffic
down white crowned
sparrows are singing new notes
researchers hope the birds will have
their
best mating season in years earlier this
week we spoke with sir david
and the documentary's executive producer
mike gutten about nature's remarkable
rebound
sir david i want to begin with you i
have a little piece of paper here that
says you can be called only david but
you'll
you'll remain sir to me yes if you don't
mind
uh you have long maintained that the
wild
the wild on this planet will survive
with us or without us
i guess during these lockdowns we kind
of got proof
yes not just the five it does rather
better
as you might imagine less noise less
fume in the air
more space what more do you want if
you're a wild animal
so natural in the history of the
creatures around us they've flourished
by and large in this last year
your crews also filmed humpback whales
in alaska where the cruise industry
was shut down what was the impact of
that what did you see with the whales
well by and large every animal has done
better without us and that's not
surprising
in this instance the whales were able to
communicate
again with their young and much better
than they were in the past
so that the young could hear their
parents the feeding some distance away
and the parents didn't mind going away
and that's why in fact the whales have
been doing very much better
mike this one's for you you know i
thought it was just me that the birds
were singing
louder and that they were clearer how
did you know that this was happening
what did you see that made you think
we need to capture it and we need to
capture it now
well funnily enough the very first thing
was bird song we were thinking so hold
on
this was this new soundscape this is
silence and suddenly we hear birds
so we all thought if we move quickly
something interesting is happening here
so
it came actually initially from the
sound of a bird song
but then it send out this wave of
exploration all around the world
mike i have a thing for penguins and you
shot penguins walking empty streets
in south africa why that was important
for the penguins
what happened there was those penguins
do kind of cohabit with people
under normal circumstances and we
thought that's fine but when lockdown
happened
the beaches were empty and what was
actually going on the penguins went out
to sea to catch food for their chicks
but when they tried to come back during
the day beaches full of people
they didn't want to come ashore they
stayed out to sea when everybody left
the penguins rather than having to wait
were coming in many many times during
the day so their chicks
were getting fed much more frequently
and the consequence of that
is that they did better some of them had
twins and some of them even had a second
brood so
again it shows us that we think we know
what's going on the natural world but
actually it was this
situation this lockdown that drew back
is almost like a
veil and let us see what actually
happens to the world when we don't tread
so heavily on it
that's a great way to put it uh sir
david back to you i i think the lesson
from this footage is that small changes
in our behavior
can have a huge impact on nature
that is the lesson do you think we're
learning it or have learned it as a
planet
biologists have all have known that all
the time the by and large
men human beings are the last arrival
biologically out of this planet and we
had to sort of edge our way into it
by pushing animals aside we've only got
to stop for
a few months and suddenly the natural
world will benefit
sir david has anybody ever told you
you've got a great voice
a global of epic proportions is what you
said in the piece
i could listen to you all day well done
gentlemen it's really beautifully done
yeah sir david attenborough and mike
gutten thank you both very much we
appreciate it
the year earth change is available now
on apple tv
plus check it out